bonsoir paul thompson merci d'être avec
nous est la question devient donc du
nord ses frontières on le sait on le
rappelle elle a été pendant trois
décennies le théâtre de troupe très
important sanglant conflit évidemment
qui oppose et républicains catholiques
partisans de la réunification avec
l'irlande
les vieux fantômes sont en train de se
réveiller
je pense que ça va se calmer assez
rapidement mais c'est vrai que c'était
un incident cette histoire d'introduire
des contrôles sur la frontière entre la
république theron et des rangs du nord a
provoqué un choc est certainement un
camp et allemand parce que pendant
toutes les années des négociations sur
le break 6 que la commission européenne
ne cessait de dire qu'il ne faut surtout
pas que l'atelier qu'il puisse y avoir
le moindre début de frontières dur sur
la sueur sur cette frontière est le fait
de réclamer elle même des contrôles est
en contradiction flagrante avec cette
position donc c'était vraiment à une une
bévue majeur mais il faut reconnaître
qu'elle était reconnu comme tel
rapidement et d'ailleurs les antilles
brésil comme des progrès si donc
exactement la même lecture de la
situation et sommes continent aussi il
ya une quasi unanimité pour dire que
c'était vraiment une
une erreur assez grossière et
inexplicable mais une erreur qu'il
s'agissait de rectifier et et ça a été
fait parce que je comprends la
commission a renoncé à de tels contrôles
donc donc ça a été une source
un incident pénible mais qui je l'espère
en tout cas ne laisserait pas de de
marque durable dans les relations entre
revenus et l'union européenne
en tout cas ça a été laborieusement
négocié entre bruxelles et londres à ce
protocole
justement qu'ils visent
c'est le comble à préserver le traité de
paix de l'accord du vendredi saint
manifestement un échec par quoi peut-on
remplacer comment peut-on finalement
rêver cette situation 2 il ya trois
questions si vous voulez en ce qui
concerne la préservation des acquis de
l'accord du vendredi saint à bord va et
il a dit d'ailleurs dans de petites la
partie dues selon que vous avez montré
que le gouvernement britannique et je
suis sûr qu'il est très sincère en
disant s'attache à préserver la
substance de cet accord et il l'aura
mais il ya tout intérêt à la faire aussi
pour assurer un bon redémarrage des
rapports avec la nouvelle administration
les nouveaux présidents américains mais
aussi parce que le dow a minina
simplement pas intérêt à créer d
encourager à une résurgence de troubles
que c'était très douloureux pour tout le
monde et y compris le droit ni pour des
irlandais du nord et du sud mais pour
les britanniques également donc ça ça ne
prenne de poing général en ce qui
concerne le coût des contrôles aux
frontières je pense que la question
avait déjà été réglée la frontière entre
le land du nord et la république devant
en ce qui concerne la question des
contrôles dans la mer d'irlande comme on
dit c'est à dire entre le vent du nord
et le reste du royaume uni ça c'est un
sujet pu compter les plus difficiles et
je ne sais pas comment savoir évoluer
marie jeune j'aurais tendance à croire
que le royaume uni ne voit pas
s'employer à éviscérer et dispositions
pertinentes de l'accord sur le retrait
nous sommes unis et et il y à une
situation nouvelle où ces contrôles sont
nouveau c'est une source d'irritation
pour les personnes qui sont directement
concernés les commerçants les
particuliers même donc ça agace les gens
on peut espérer que ça se calme avec
avec l' usage de même que entre calais
et douvres il ya des quelques frictions
à cause de ces nouveautés avec des
formulaires douaniers mais bon set up il
aura une courbe d'apprentissage comme on
dit qui fera j'espère que ça va se
calmer progressivement
c'était la guerre des bac 5 et l origine
de ces nouvelles frictions
est ce qu'on doit tout de même
s'attendre à d'autres tensions
prochainement parce qu'on le sait la
situation est compliquée sur le terrain
concrètement je pense qu'il ya un jeu
intéressant qui dépasse les rangs du
nord les questions des vaccins aussi
importante que soient ces questions est
ce jeu général la de positionnement ou
rechercher respectivement par le groupe
le royaume uni son gouvernement d'une
part et la commission et de votre auto
de rien d'autre part dans ce monde post
pratique de l'union de la droite unie
très actif sur le front diplomatique
elle a déjà posé une demande d'adhésion
à cette zone de libre commerce au
pacifique où il ya déjà onze pays
elle a continué à conclure des accords
de libre commerce avec différents
pilotes et air s 300 2 mais il y a
quinze jours ghana peut-être plus
maintenant et
je pense que mon assurance et son équipe
parce qu'il a vécu très soudé capable
autour de lui des gens qui ont beaucoup
de personnalités qui sont des battants
veulent dire au monde montrer au monde
que le royaume uni va utiliser cette
émancipation en trouver un grand bout
pour agir tous librement avec tous
d'agilité dans toutes sortes de domaines
et à cette affaire des vaccins est
exploité je pense que c'est assez
évident de penser de bonne guerre à
cette fin c'est à dire qu'on montrait
que est justement de la reprise du
contrôle et la croix de 2,2 d'agilité de
souplesse de liberté de manoeuvre est
très payant y compris sur des sujets
d'importance vitale comme une celui des
vaccins face à cette horrible pandémie
donc il ya cette dimension politique
même métapolitique plus large qui joue
aussi
mais tout ça ne devrait pas empoisonner
durablement les rapports entre laura
meunier l'union européenne se savent ça
fait partie du jeu si vous voulez donc
il ne faut pas 100 moines lille s'en
émouvoir pendant ni sont inquiétés à mon
avis merci beaucoup pas là thomson vice
président du parti conservateur à paris
d'avoir été avec nous